we're back from Sony's e3 2015 press
conference everybody make you freak out
noise right now because we show okay Wow
no I mean I was here for that unless
there's some sort of scarecrow thing
going on in this room and Twitter all of
Twitter yeah what's the opposite of fear
toxin like hey boy wish-fulfillment
toxin all right yes we can take a
measure to an ordered approach to
dissecting all that awesomeness I don't
know about Danny was trying to keep them
along with us but first shenmue
Kickstarter currently at five hundred
and twenty eight thousand we'll be
checking in on that throughout our post
show it's going so faster every now and
then when you're fresh it says 1000 I
don't know what's happening alright
first let's start at the beginning let's
start with Last Guardian The Last
Guardian doors start with the last guy
that's what Sony said and boom there it
was we saw a like teen boy and bird dog
like gallivanting around the world what
did you guys think of this showing did
it was it worth the 17-year wait it
looks so much better than it looked that
like this it it has the same it like it
looks like that demo from all those
years ago yeah yeah it's got the same
kind of feel to it same like mood and
wash but they showed so much like they
couldn't just show three seconds it's a
show like a five minute gameplay yeah I
think they needed to build that car back
up I mean they're done a bunch of things
to kind of restore some of our
confidence there was a lot of talk about
whatever Fumito a widow was still a part
of it yes and they led with his name and
he was even in the crowd they'll talk
about him leaving in a bit over half so
it's good to see him there and he didn't
seem like he was like there under duress
it seemed like he was happy and of there
of his own volition totally yeah I mean
and you can clearly tell like well you
know whether the
is whether he still you know continued
to contribute on it and actually worked
and in the long run you can still get a
good you know taste of the fact that he
did yeah he was involved heavily in it
you can feel his presence there you can
feel it in the area feather physics
thing is it makes knows on paper that
should be the most hideous ugly thing
ever a bird dog chicken it's like a
beautiful face creature you know it's
called blue is the gross chicken this
but when he roared here I thought you
sound like a t-rex when he thinks you're
in danger we what he's scared to move in
here also that kids running down the
stairs animation is the best kind of
brings his knees up just a bit too big
that was a good start and it's mean 2016
2016 I think that was a bit of a like a
moment were like ah I have to wait even
longer it turns out there's enough
really good game I don't know I think I
got to be a little bit of a naysayer on
the Last Guardian rubric this puzzle
this environmental situation is like
really simplistic and I mean it's a demo
I understand the context and like I
loved a lot of the animation stuff a lot
of the sort of evocative nature of their
relationship it's a lot to like but when
it comes to sustaining a game over the
course of many hours that's gonna have
to change somehow it's gonna like this
part you're like he's like clearly like
oh I gotta I'm not gonna not gonna run
really fast cuz I want to well it's
dangerous I'm still here I mean I could
just run okay I mean I don't know so
again I was like trying to withhold a
little bit of excitement just because
they forget from a gameplay perspective
they didn't show too much yeah I mean
the studio is known for taking really
simple concepts and and doing amazing
yeah like if you look at the phone let's
say 10 15 minutes of echo or shadow you
none of the Colossus their first
Colossus you fight is impressive but you
wouldn't expect that to kind of be I
think that you'd be excited about over
the course of a long game and and the
way they kind of iterate on that and
they make it more exciting over the
course of many many hours I mean that's
what their experts are doing taking a
core concept and just kind of messing
with it over the course of multiple
hours and I fully expected them to do
the same thing here alright that's the
last Guardian coming 2016 at long last
it's back on the Sony stage at e3 all
right then we went so we went right from
the Last Guardian to a completely new
game folks at guerrilla games yeah and
this one I feel like jumped immediately
to my front runner for a game of show I
its horizon zero dawn and it just looks
fantastic I got a crazy like enslaved
vibe of post-apocalypse elute Lee it's
that sort of nature the nature bound to
decay like nature has flourished the
decay is the bones of like long long ago
and you know you even get that vibe
reinforced by the sort of society of
humans that are more sort of a primitive
kind of a tribal look then and this is
the great reveal you at first you're
like what kind of weird animal is doing
this scan thing but then you realize
she's not hunting animals she's hunting
machines to what end is it for like are
they using these materials and their
compounds aunty robots the compound bow
she's got like the weapons she's using
the knife are clearly compiled like made
from parts scrap together but I think
that they echoed the idea of an
ecosystem here you have these machines
busted up oh yeah that it's just so
fascinating this inversion of many of
technology versus nature I mean they Lou
to a kind of story about how the
machines kind of left the human kind and
became presses in a way cuz you know she
seems to be preparing for a larger
machine invasion or like uprising of a
human kind of species interesting they
make such beautiful eyes looking games
and like the Killzone games for me I've
always been relatively mechanically
uninteresting like shadow fall actually
probably
interesting Killzone game I thought I
would play but what's what's happening
here with the like it's almost like like
crazy big boss fight first of all it's a
third person game which gorilla that's
completely grand for them then like this
kind of almost had like a sort of a
Monster Hunter vibe where you were like
picking apart different bits of the the
monster like it looks so much more
interesting
I'm so glad gorilla doing something
different because I was like the
killzone I like personally I've always
think or thought of it as kind of a
mediocre first person issue that's
that's always looked amazing and I want
to see that studio do something
different which they are now and it
looks so much different from what
they're going for what they did before I
mean they could have you know played it
safe and done a new type of first-person
shooter when they did something
completely different which I am I'm kind
of excited for and I respect Sony for
giving them the opportunity to do that
it looks looks incredible looks stunning
and there was this moment when she kills
one of the and like the creatures early
on she sort of puts a knife in it and
says sorry little one so there's this
compassion for these creatures this kind
of like they're not just it's not a
terminator situation where it's like oh
god the machines you know it's like this
is the dynamic there is fascinating I
think Danny your reference to enslaved
earlier on comes back around to sort of
this this connection to technology as
something that's not impersonal but yes
that we can't have a connection with
like it's been there longer than they
have even you know it's like pre it's a
precursor to their problems civilization
the other thing I've got him from the
list locomotion what was that game you
had the jetpacks on your legs you're
running around 360 thang wish I wish I
got a real vanquish 5 off this okay a
monster hunter and Dragon's Dogma vibe
from had these massive like and the bow
and arrow part of it but yeah it looks
it looks incredible
that's horizon zero dawn making a big
splash at Sony's press conference here
at e3 2015 now right after that are
closely on the heels of that Media
Molecule brought out something that was
really and I just want to talk about it
for a minute because there wasn't a lot
to grab onto you know is very like oh
yeah you just like you can paint
anything and it could be a person and
you could tell that the or a bear or a
bad person with a bear head just sort of
this like creative palette kind of yeah
it seems like they like weave
this canvas for you just go walled with
it I mean we predicted that Media
Molecule would be on the stage with
something weird and they did show up
with something and I'd weird like the
stuff that he was drawing was like that
thing looks kind of ugly but at the same
time it's kind of fascinating to look at
I mean it's an interesting idea and it's
kind of in their territory where they're
you know creating worlds for people to
explore and share and that kind of thing
it's it's just a lot like
LittleBigPlanet but this dream verse
which they're talking about is quite
interesting I want to see more of it
it's weird it's one of those annoying
developer things well they're like I
know you have questions yeah but that's
the whole point it's going by a question
what are you just explain it to me but
in a way it doesn't even feel like a
game it's like media molecules peyote
simulators like it because I guess
making the thing is the game but like in
terms of game played very much TV it's
almost like a machinima tool or
something yeah yeah but it's it's got
you know you've got Media Molecule has
experience obviously with creation tools
LittleBigPlanet you know and then you
have other tons of creation tools in
gaming Garry's Mod of course one of them
but this doesn't look like anything else
it's it's it seems like once once you
see like how different you get the
things you can create just immediately
brings to mind Microsoft Project spark
thing yeah which is like this is Sony
clearly Sony's answer to project spark
which is kind of awesome like everyone
giving people the chance to create
something and you know share it and that
kind of stuff it's always welcome
because I mean project spark is way to
create in for a lot of people but the
stuff that's in maze some of its really
fascinating and I'm just so excited to
see this these kind of creation sweets
dreams it looks like trying to be freed
from the shackles of a unifying
aesthetic like it doesn't all look the
same it was the big finest problem was
that everything just looked like little
big it was super cute but what if you're
not like feeling super cute feeling like
a bear beheaded pianist with a raven
just bursted in a bird's eye like this
just seems like the emotional palette
for creativity it could be so much
broader yeah yeah all right we also had
a big review we also had a big adventure
with no man's sky during the Sony press
conference here at e3 2015
Marie takes the stage he's sort of doing
his flying
he's like shooting a dude and then he
goes into that galaxy view yeah it's
like okay pulls out a little bit like
these are all you see you know what a
hundred stars on screen these are all
stars with solar systems that have
planets you can explore and then he just
like goes off the rails and is flying at
Lightyear speed throughout the galaxy
it's like that thing you do you know
when you're like having a couple of
drinks at a Friday night you get in
front of YouTube and a sudden you're
watching like Carl Sagan videos lie down
on the floor for a minute just to feel
like you're not gonna float off into
nothingness and they just picks a planet
around impressive the way that it all
worked and came together and it was just
seamless the week just landed and then
of course oh now I'm underwater
yeah yes III fishery fish this planet
III cuz chances are none of you're gonna
find it because we're all so
insignificant and people have to play
this game for a billion years before
anyone we discover but you know that's
got to be a thing now right there's
gonna be this cadre of people on the
hunt for soo Goswami fine there III fish
and be the first ones to get there I
wonder how long that's gonna take
something in the way Shaun Murray
presented at this time you nervous yes
just like I'm doing this and he was
quite like like steam rolling through
whatever he wanted to show like I'm
gonna do this now I'm less like shaky
voice face touchy kind of yeah when they
showed the stuff at e3 before like I saw
behind closed doors and there wasn't
like there was an element of smoke and
mirrors with that snow like they hadn't
really figured out a lot of these
systems or they weren't like working
properly yet it's clear that you can
always tell by Sean with his beard if
he's been working yeah he got this
programming beard so now he's got his
beard he's probably been like
hard-coding for about six months so you
can tell the Nair this is actually he
definitely seems like his demeanor seems
like he's more confident in way showing
I guess it helps that like the world
went absolutely mental after they've
showed it for the first few times so
he's like he seems like he's he feels
like everyone's on board and they just
want to see more of it and he's doing
that very shortly I mean it was expertly
crafted demo showing everything you
wanted to how much space you have and
this is what you can do in there this is
all the stuff that you will see and it's
just like man
crafted and also just kind of random and
rearrange them yeah this great
undercurrent of surprise like I'm just
gonna try to go to this planet yeah it
worked out okay and then he warps in
cool yeah alright this works genuine as
well no staged demo kind of thing I was
like yeah this dogfighting is trading
all the games play modes and all that
stuff and let's move on crazy no man's
sky on the Sony stage here at e3 2015
all right let's take a let's let's
address the number two in the timorous
trifecta of predictions here everyone
going bonkers for final fantasy because
worlds of final fantasy and everyone
just sort of sign up a little bit and
then this came on everyone just where
was it world of Final Fantasy yeah
developers of this they've been reduced
to a gag now set up to a punchline I'm
sorry but with Final Fantasy remake and
those cutscenes you who can stand
toe-to-toe with that I mean we saw it I
don't know I Final Fantasy 7 I don't
have like giant outpouring on the style
before I played it a little bit but
everyone they're just losing their minds
everyone around the world
you know Final Fantasy 7 remake crazy
happening and it looks like they've
actually put in some effort yes which is
surprising like if you think they just
do like a standard shot-for-shot remake
type thing yeah it looks like they've
they've added little more depth to the
narrative the way the the kind of the
narrator was talking about the stuff
happening in the city it looks like
they've they've kind of up the story and
made it boy into the modern day with
better writing and kind of presentation
and characters let's see what the
gameplay is because like we were
expecting an HD remake like an HD remake
of what is essentially an isometric
turn-based action game is different if
they end up like doing this in the
engine that the new ones in or even
something like a 3d engine yes that is
that is a good point like
is that game plugin because Final
Fantasy and Square Enix has moved away
from turn-based quite so is this gonna
be a turn-based game or is it gonna be
something closer to like final fantasy
15 kingdom hearts that kind of thing
where it's more action focused it's a
remake yeah I reckon it will probably be
a lot more action focus the way Kingdom
Hearts is but I'm down for that like I'd
rather not play another turn-based
version of the same game just numbers
but yeah it looks it looks pretty
amazing finally everyone can stop
moaning about yeah it's happening very
few games so knees just knocked them all
down like this just move on before a
yesterday and then Sony just did
basically today Fantasy 7 remake yeah it
seemed like it said debut on PlayStation
4 so might be a Xbox version coming soon
maybe with a PC version yeah that's
Final Fantasy 7 and a quick check in on
Shenmue 3 Kickstarter watch now at six
hundred and sixty two thousands good
dollars it will be funded by the pledge
of the two million dollar goal yeah so
let's talk about Shenmue 3 the third of
the oh my god I can't believe they did
that but a little bit they would like to
make this game we're not gonna fund it
you guys can just I think it was a great
springboard for the Kickstarter yes
certainly so they haven't like gone into
details about what this means yeah right
the big rumor that was going around was
that there would be a Kickstarter and
then if it actually made it what they
its goal that then Sony would front the
rest I mean that two million dollars is
what they asked for that is not enough
no it's not to make a game so Sony may
not have said it yet but clearly someone
else is getting involved too like this
is gonna overshoot two million dollars
by a significant amount but I still
don't think it's gonna be enough to
fully fund a game like Shenmue 3 in the
way that they want to make it and the
way that we want to play it so if my if
I had to bet I'd I reckon that Sony will
still cough up some cash for it we're
yet to confirm that he hasn't said
anything or explained it this is gonna
blaze past its goal into like I mean a
game development
now in the hundreds of millions yeah for
like you know most modern-day games so
it's gonna take a lot more than most
kick stars yeah I mean if it reaches
hundreds of millions then it's probably
gonna be the craziest kick star of all
time
well yeah it's it's good to see it's
finally out but that is what a lot of
games are doing on Kickstarter now just
while we started this yeah
I you know with the Castlevania II
garages Castlevania announcement he's
straight up said listen I have backers
that are providing 90% of the funding
for this game
they just need like the it's like the
show of faith like it's the proof of an
audience that Kickstarter provides and
so maybe that's more of what this is you
know if it's a drop in the bucket of the
game design budget it's proof that
people want it and if judging judging
from the reaction of folks at the
Convention Center and also here Shenmue
3 is something that people are really
I've done I'm not surprised
I reckon Sony will get probably I mean
it's it's a way win-win scenario if it
reaches his Kickstarter because I mean
fans of the classic this is everything
they've ever wanted and for Sony they
can just start cranking up the marking
machine to present it as a new IP to
people who've never played it before
like this is a game that's got so much
lineage and heritage you should check it
out that kind of thing so if Sony does
get involved it's it's in their benefit
and for the rest of us we get to play
Shenmue free if it sucks because it
wasn't by the time cuz most of Europe's
asleep right now except for the clever
people who stayed up to watch this good
by the time everyone watches this
on-demand on GameSpot calm that thing's
already funded yeah yeah it's going at
an incredible pace the Shenmue 3
Kickstarter up announced at press
conference here at e3 2015 now a lot of
Sony's show was actually taken up by
third-party games non Sony exclusives
but stuff that they were showcasing
stuff that Microsoft didn't showcase
sort of exclusivity stuff that they we
were talking about before the show so
let's run through a few of those quickly
I think the first one to surface was
Assassin's Creed syndicate
yeah showed up Evie
and oh my god she is nasty Oh cane sword
let's just flip the dude up on a table
and he got squished oh yeah she's like
killing dudes in this industrial foundry
she tosses one dude into the molten
metal clean yeah I love that how is the
complete opposite of what Jacobs
narration was trying to present her as
like as this she's figured out the
subtleties of you know dealing with and
she's like no I'm just straight-up yeah
she is clear in this place out
Assassin's Creed syndicate one of the
third-party things to show up in Sony's
press conference of course we also had
destiny the taken King a man Eric Taylor
losing his mind him and I'm very excited
we got a glimpse of some of the new
subclasses for the three for the Titan
warlock and Hunter I think I saw like a
glowing axe at one point there was like
an emperor palpatine esque lightning
hands like and then maybe a bow and
arrow and it was glowing summoned and
you know it's a more Hummer 40k nonsense
whether those are sort of in-game events
rate specific stuff or whether they are
actually the subclass is I don't know
perfect for certain prey yes Tommy Hawks
both by the I am dead now I must live
again my dad told me how to use it my
space draws hammer that's what it is
look at this hammer time as someone
who's taken a character up to level 25
and just got bored with doing the same
crap over and over again I'm kind of
excited to get back into it check it out
it looks like ya might have put in a
little work a game that you are probably
going to hit the ground running during
in though two more Street Fighter 5 yep
two new characters buddy and
Cammi they knew yeah so buddy and cami
brand new to this game they her but he
hasn't been seen since alpha three he
looks cool played a bit of him fun
character he's got loads of gimmicks
like food based gimmicks great food
throws I might use like rolling energy
cans at you and he drink cans at you so
yeah his cool and Kami's just really all
about like pressure and lockdown and
that kind of stuff but I think the more
important thing is they announced the
beta which is gonna be starting in July
July 23rd exclusive ps4 if it's if it's
anything like what I've played it's a
pretty it's a really good example of the
final game I reckon I go I played it and
I was like man this is this is solid
like I can't see them doing anything
drastic to it it looks amazing every
time I see it looks even better but I
reckon they finally reached a point
where it actually looks quite good and
so I reckon it's worth checking out even
if you're a casual fan of flying games
also saw some Batman Arkham Knight but
then the big third-party steal here for
Sony was the call of duty black ops 3
they're getting the map packs first now
the era of Xbox getting those is over
yeah we thought as much when we saw that
it didn't pop up on Microsoft stage
which is a staple for them and this is
really kind of like the the nail in the
coffin in terms of exclusivity Sony ran
again not only like all these massive
you know fan favorites crazy games
people have wanted forever but they're
locking and the Triple A exclusivity
stuff as well and like for I think
tomorrow you can probably empathize with
this from working in read games retail
this sort of stuff matters to people
they want and they know that all the
stuffs gonna come out on one of them
they go Armani a Call of Duty that's an
Xbox game you know be fair that's an
Xbox iam when when they start to get
exclusivity on these consoles it really
changes the minds of people in terms of
what consoles they want to I said this
is a big get for sale yeah I mean people
a lot of people they'll buy something
like a ecology and FIFA and they're kind
of locked into that game for a year or
so and that means like when you're
buying you they want to know that they
will be supported going forward so I
mean when it comes to retail something
like Call of Duty exclusive Eve of DLC
might not mean much to you know the most
of the most gaming order
but for a large portion of it outside of
you know the casual type players and the
people who buy a game and commit to that
one thing for a long time that is huge
and it will translate the sales for Sony
yeah and the only other thing it does it
has this crazy ripple effect where when
people are especially casual but like
soft core gamers people who bought like
two or three games a year when they get
used to using one controller oh yes
stick with me so if they can get people
to buy call of duty on the console then
that also means that their lot more
likely to buy every other game going
forward on that cause it's a big play
for that it's that thing where FIFA
buttons vs. BOTS totally it's a game
that like if you if you play fifa like
chances are you'll never touch a PES
game because you just can't comprehend
how it works it's the same with any
other yearly franchise Call of Duty a
big get and then we saw a Star Wars
Battlefront at the end close to the end
of Sony's press conference a new map
that we hadn't really seen in action yet
and so definitely like some Sony fingers
on that one exclusive
you heard it here yeah we had more than
a few sort of character lusts sort of
exclamations as the Boba Fett figurine
popped up there any of you guys into
collecting on his desk oh really
sorely tempted by the group so not only
a big showing for oh my god wonderful
surprises at Sony but also for
third-party games and Sony little
chipping away at that exclusivity deal
and then of course Sony wrapped up their
press conference here at e3 2015 with
uncharted 4 you're so good they showed
it twice the first shock for sinking
look at this market see how many people
we can put on screen at the power of the
PlayStation they're all just acting
natural all right now you reckon they
just roll tape then the second time
right I was like yeah I'm a module
sharks not connect what's that guy doing
with that pole over there
there's a lot of people on the screen
and so that demo proceeded started off
very uncharted feeling yeah sort of
uncharted 3 where you're playing is
young Nate and you market after Sully
and I'll tell you me that's what kind of
reminisce minded me of and then you know
the two of them get together and form
this formidable team destructibility
here it's like some young easy new
version of counter-strike like CS italy
or something yeah
chunks of stuff flying all over the
place a lot of stuff being smashed
around a lot of like just objects loose
in the environment that you're kicking
around this combat very uncharted
feeling as you're sort of battling
through games looking gorgeous but then
a little bit later they hop into a truck
yeah they've never been driving as I've
been a driving sequence in Uncharted
before I must have been in or at least
jumped this is just like unshackling
from kind of like the lead corridor kind
of like it's not you could have gone
left to right there very obviously
signposting where you need to go next
it's kind of like I mean they're doing
it from through intuitive design and
it's not immediately apparent there's
not a giant arrow pointing saying go
this way just like you could I mean
hopefully there's not a fence thing if
he Chuck's her right here and just
something well they're like the best
sort of action games they giving you the
illusion of an okay exact which is
enough you know and Uncharted has
certainly done that to great success in
their press in their past I mean it's
always been a series that's been about
creating that that illusion of options
you know and that illusion of oh my god
I just picked this crazy path along the
way that was so great even though
there's no other way you could've gone
but they sell it right they sell it well
and they certainly sell this well and we
all just started laughing delightedly as
he's just bombarding down rooms and then
like a monster truck over a huge bunch
of parked cars I think the thing that I
like most about is up until now we've
seen quite
the dark imagery and we've had the guys
from the last of us taking over and
being like oh this is gonna be a greedy
and darker story about you know Nate and
his brother and his weird history that
they have together and him abandoning
his friend but it's good to see that
they still have the kind of like Indiana
Jones this is just crazy fun romp kind
of angle to it to Nate is Sully
equipping their way through life in
general graduations literally everything
it's just like the great one line is it
still there like what is it I I got it I
got it I don't got it yeah hold on does
he hit this goat I looked like you did
the first time I go is running fast
think that you've reached the adrenaline
just do one more thing uncharted for a
thief's end wrapping up Sony's e3 press
conference here at e3 2015 this has been
the end of a long day of press
conferences we've had for today and one
last night that's five of seven we're
gonna be seeing tomorrow we've got a
Nintendo Direct in the morning and then
Square Enix yep so yeah so it's a little
too early to tally all of the the press
conferences told but certainly heavy
hitters today and last night with
Bethesda Microsoft EA Ubisoft and Sony
let's get some general impressions here
what do you I mean how are you guys
feeling about Colin 3 this might be my
and if and if it is then Sony's
presentation
you cannot like to bring out like one
game is like that everyone's been
looking forward to this e3 we have had
four there's very few games that exist
in the realm of like desire and
speculation that fallout 4 The Last of
Us a Final Fantasy 7 HD remake and then
on top of that like Shenmue 3 like what
rumors are gonna write
is crazy we shy it down all of these
games would be looking forward to
forever like it it's just absolutely
insane and it's insane that they are
cashing all those checks in one press
conference or in one show in the space
of 24 hours we've had like a lot of good
conferences let's not forget Microsoft
conference it was actually really good
just like it's the end of the day of the
reporting cycle you know like that work
tomorrow is a new day at the e3 new news
coming but like for me I think the
highlight one the highlight of the day I
think for me is still that hololens demo
watching that minecraft thing just
captured my imagination of like
possibility and creativity and the
future of games in a way that I was not
like it's there I'm optimistic about VR
and all that stuff but to see it like
manifested so clearly yeah and
functioning yeah I think that's why they
really had the one up over Sony's that
Sony basically said Morpheus then they
were like oh this is eSports for
Morpheus but then didn't really show ya
anything but Microsoft just laid it out
in front of you and just it was
wonderful yeah good point Morpheus was
actually really scaled back the edge so
much at all they were I mean we should
have had a release date and a price
which we didn't get which is suspicious
and kind of weird or even just some like
big heavy hitter games like the no man's
sky maybe beyond or a bunch of Indies
maybe they just haven't had enough time
because man I mean this game comment
Paris games week which is gonna have a
big presence at each of those so might
as well save it for them and for them
yeah all right some more Lucey Danny I'm
sorry
how's Shenmue doing I my browser says
eight hundred and forty four thousand
great dang that was on 31 days that's
hope they reach it yeah good luck
Shenmue 3 man if that game comes on it
sucks
never won for anything yep alright some
more Lucy Danny thank you so much for
joining me here for the Sony press
conference post show thanks to everyone
here on the GameSpot States you talked
about press conferences all day today
come on back tomorrow because we are
starting early with Nintendo
someone tell me when that is while I'm
still talking right now yeah thank you
9 a.m. tomorrow we are gonna be live
talking about Nintendo seeing what
they've got to show off then they're
Square Enix and of course the kickoff of
GameSpot's live stage show from the show
floor at e3 at 1:00 p.m. tomorrow stay
tuned folks come back and see us
tomorrow it's gonna be great III